Ryan have you ever have you ever done
any songwriting you have so many other
jobs and things you're great at so well
as a matter of fact
when I was on Malcolm in the Middle yeah
I used to uh
our audience is in love with y'all I
used to my character used to hum and
whistle a lot oh yes
and then I got a call from the the music
supervisor at fox saying uh are you a
member of BMI or ASCAP and I said no why
he goes well because I need to write
down every second of music on a show and
you're whistling and humming unless
you're whistling and humming someone
else's work anyway how dare you this is
these are original original and so to
this day I will get a check it said Hal
humming two seconds
Hal whistling second and a half oh my
gosh so it got to a point where I was
collecting these little checks and I
would cash them and buy uh drinks for
all the for all the crew oh yeah oh I
love that and sometimes a crew member
would come by and say hey Brian it looks
like a a good opportunity for Hal to
whistle on his way to the car and I go
you just want a drink all right we know
where that money's gonna go you should
do an album called Whistle While You
Work and just have it be your Whistling
song exactly
that's the producer
but I have I have watched her sing in so
many different plays I saw her it open
for Chicago the band Chicago you're
fantastic in 54 Below I've seen you
that's right and in other places and
you're marvelous I mean you really are
you're not just I think you're my buddy
I paid him to say that no it's so cool
though like I said when the world's
collide as well and you get to oh I feel
like I get to do it here I get to do the
show but I still get to involve music
exactly it's nice when that happens yeah
it breaks up the monotony I it's
hilarious you just said whistling I'm
like Jocko is actually whistling on my
new album that's coming out he's
actually the beginning of a whole song
with his whistle I just was thinking
that when you were whistling I was like
that's hysterical there it goes
literally opening up my album possibly
but
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]